now also developing vaccine mandates are
ramping up from coast to coast raising
more questions about threats to medical
privacy and threat to personal freedom
and get this according to the associated
press the bite administration is even
floating vaccine mandates for interstate
travel hello airports or even changing
how the federal government reimburses
treatment for those who are unvaccinated
and catch covet 19. here for reaction
fox news contributor my friend laura
trump along with fox news medical
contributor who should be the cc cdc
director dr nicole sapphire hey partners
hang team how you doing
laura let me go to youtube
let me go to you first laura laura it
seems to me that the democrats want to
hold on to this so-called pandemic
crisis take away our freedom employ more
federal regulation one size fit all and
that's why you hear this floating trial
balloon of the idea of an interstate
passport requiring everyone to be
vaccinated what say you on this
yeah it's absolutely unbelievable and
leo i almost didn't recognize you
without your hat on
but you're doing a great job hosting
hannity tonight i love to see it i'm
trying to get my hands on one of those
hats
look the reality is it is a it is a one
size fits all approach with the bind
administration but if you look at this
overall it really seems like there's a
lot more here than just trying to keep
americans safe the reality is this is so
much about control and if you are trying
to socialize a country and ultimately
turn america into a socialist nation
then maybe you go along and you see just
how far you can push people how long can
you lock people down how long can you
make everybody wear masks how long can
you make our kids in school wear masks
gosh are we going to have to have a
vaccine passport to drive on the
interstates it is ludicrous that anyone
is suggesting this especially whenever
we have a fully open southern border
with over 200 000 apprehensions we know
of last month alone with coveted
positive
people flowing over our southern border
going throughout the country yet the
american people are being punished gosh
it seems like if you wanted to get away
with anything quite frankly just come
over the southern border and you got a
free pass absolutely dr cole tell me
what the one size
fits all does it work for me as a lawyer
i'm sure from a medical standpoint i
look at the different exemptions for
people who have medical conditions
people who have already
been uh who have pre-existing conditions
and i look at religious freedom personal
freedoms i look at the medical excuses
that might be used by individuals the
federal government is not a doctor i
mean
shouldn't this type of decision be in
the hands of medical professionals not
the federal government
well leo as you say it's not black and
white and to laura's point when did the
united states become such a hegemon that
we not only do we dominate the global
supply of vaccines and we're not giving
it to countries to help people so that
we can lessen the transmission globally
but as you start talking about these
vaccine mandates first of all yes it
should always be a conversation between
a physician and their patient listen
vaccine mandates are not uncommon when
it comes to health care workers
international travel but when you start
talking about going into a restaurant
interstate travel and then that ap
article that you referenced saying that
they're starting to decide that maybe
people who are unvaccinated should be
reimbursed or cared for differently if
they are to contract copin 19 i mean
that's preposterous i mean we spend
about as a country 300 billion dollars
every year
on cigarette smoking about nearly 500
000 americans die every year because of
cigarette smoking and tobacco-related
products that's not just during a crisis
that's every single year so can we stop
looking at this through our microcosm
and microscopic views and look at the
big picture here we have a lot of things
that are costing the our country a lot
of money a lot of things that are
causing death when it comes to these
vaccines it's not one size fits all the
cdc is criminal in the sense that they
are not recognizing natural immunity you
have many other countries at this point
who recognize natural immunity is made
is not only maybe as effective as the
vaccines but maybe even better if you
look at the israeli data and on top of
that outside of the united states you
don't have young children being masked
in schools because there's no data
showing that the benefit benefit of that
actually outweighs the harm that it
potentially could do to these young
people the united states actually has to
start following the science and they
need to get away from their narrative in
this myopic push to just vaccinate
everyone we have to think of people as
individuals it's not necessarily always
about the collective i agree with 200
percent laura let me go to you because i
find the political gains mission by the
democrats offensive and i'm talking
about how the white house has been going
after a floor that governor desantis is
in florida i find it offensive they're
going after him it's pure politics
what's working in florida the democrats
don't like it and they're playing
political games how do you see it
well you're exactly right they're
terrified of the fact that ron desantis
has done such a great job with covet
actually i am coming to you right now
from the state of florida i just moved
here because of the great job that
governor desantis has done it is a free
and open state um but think back to your
point about it all being political think
back to how joe biden and kamala harris
had no problem politicizing the vaccine
for their benefit during the campaign
remember that they were all nervous
about donald trump developing a vaccine
now that they're in charge they want
every single person to get it so which
one is it joe and kamala which way do
you want it it's all about politics and
the american people sadly are the ones
hurt by this we are the ones being
forced into a box forced to do so many
things um but they know that their
approach isn't working americans are fed
up with it and look around the world in
the uk and france and australia
thousands of people pushing back on
mandates on lockdowns on all of it it's
gonna come for joe and kamala after a
while i got a leo 2.0 hat for laura
trump and dr nicole sapphire i want to
thank both of you for being on handy
tonight i'll see you again